[Musique]
la plus grande équipe de super héros de
tous les temps les sept
est ce que je peux vous renseigner sur
autre chose je suis pas la porte balader
je sais ce qui est arrivé en ville n'est
pas le seul donc les super font des
centaines de victimes tous les ans pur
dommages collatéraux là où les magasins
intervient
mais une branlée quand ils franchissent
la ligne rouge
[Musique]
tu peut la gérer ce te plaît faut
vraiment se détendent le fion pourquoi
vous passez votre temps à vous disputez
comme de pépin on a du temps devant
je suis invincible abrutis deux fils de
je suis le plus grand de tous les super
héros qui j'ai le droit de faire
absolument tout ce que je veux on est
sur le point de coincer ces connards je
me casse la grève
qu'est-ce que mail ci devient cette
[__] de mail ci qu'est ce qu'elle
devient j'en sais rien emma elle fait
même pas la page 6 du daily mail vous
voyez quand on les prend à part elles
sont nuls à chier elle sert à rien mais
quand on les fout ressemble on a les
[__] de spasmes ce que je veux dire
c'est qu'on a besoin les uns des autres
et le jour il ya pris l'équipe endura le
mec sort vraiment des discours de merde
on ne peut pas faire pire
[Musique]
je sais pas je sais maintenant la [__]
détente
[Musique]
on est les sept les êtres les plus
puissants du monde espèce de sous mais
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît beaucoup
je vous en prie désolé pour le bordel
bande de sale fils de [__]
[Musique]